The animals who are
filmed for "Hostile Planet"
have to survive in
incredibly tough conditions.
But they're adapted to it.
The crew, on the
other hand, that's
a whole different ball game.
RENEE GODFREY: Making a
series like "Hostile Planet"
wasn't simple.
We filmed on every continent
on Earth with over 270 people
on our cruise.
And it took us over
three years to make.
OK, might be worth turning
your cameras on, gentlemen.
[animals screech]
TOM HUGH-JONES:
Inevitably, if you're
going to follow the animals
that are having to survive
in the most extreme
corners of the planet,
you have to go there too.
And you get a slight taste
of what their lives are like,
and it's brutal.
MATEO WILLIS: Mountains
are a unique environment.
There are other places which
are hotter, like deserts.
And there are places which
are colder, like the Arctic.
Surprisingly, the greatest
challenge in mountains
is gravity.
Because everything is an
effort against gravity.
Everything is trying
to push you down.
All right, let's do this
before any rocks fall.
Probably the thing that
shocked and surprised me most
were these little barnacle
geese chicks in Greenland.
They would walk to
the edge of a cliff,
and then they would
throw themselves
off, plummeting to the bottom.
And then they would
hit the bottom
and stand up and walk away.
And you just think,
how does life
survive something so extreme
as falling hundreds of feet?
I would be just
shattered into pieces.
And yet this tiny
little gosling,
you know, no bigger than a
couple of inches, doesn't.
[birds chirping]
Another day in the office.
MATEO WILLIS: Filming the
barnacle geese on those cliffs
was probably the single
trickiest thing to accomplish.
We needed to get a shot
where I wanted the camera
over the top of that nest.
We needed to see what
those chicks were seeing.
We needed to know what
it felt to look over
that edge for the first time.
And the only way to
do that was to get
an 8 meter crane with
a camera on the end
swung out over that nest.
But of course, there was
no area to put the crane.
You were on this tiny ledge
that was, say, no bigger
than a couple of doormats.
And so you had to balance
the entire crane and all
the weights on top of
it, so you probably
had 250 pounds of weights
and an $80,000 camera
on the other end of the crane.
And then you had to somehow
swing it over and get it
out there without
everything giving
way and collapsing around you.
More speed and pan to the left.
And that was probably
the only time
I've ever stopped and
thought, is this really worth
it for the shot? if
it all goes wrong,
is it worth it for one shot?
And it was.
[birds whooping]
[music playing]